I was like these people are like they've
got all the big forces and the world
against them and they're still holding
it down it's like what is this thing man
there was this ridiculous video that I
saw of this CNN journalist she was prone
and she was like oh my god there thing
we're currently like oh yeah and there's
people walking in the back strolling or
on bicycles they have to try man they
have to try so hard they have to try so
hard to keep the lie up you know and but
it's but they're being exposed and
they're taking the L man they're just
like going to look like
fools welcome back to the realest
podcast in the the three Muslims today
alhamdulillah it's finally happening we
have with us IM Tom my brother how you
do doing well great to we've been
hanging for the week so it's great not
our first time meeting alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah and inshallah not our last
either Y for the viewers that are tuning
in what would be a quick revert story in
a nutshell oh boy okay so quick revert
story in three acts okay act one I was
uh a very religious young man okay I got
my first Bible I was given when I was 12
years old I tried to read it front to
back and I never got through it but I
literally like like read it until I was
falling asleep I always had the sense
that you know that we should be working
for for God you know what I mean and
actually I actually developed a little
bit of frustration with uh most
Christians just like not doing a whole
lot just showing up to church on Sunday
singing a few songs going home and that
was somehow enough I felt even at that
point that it wasn't enough uh act two
is when I left Christianity and religion
entirely became an atheist okay and that
was for several reasons like one of them
was actually actually the um I remember
sitting in a sermon where um you know
the pastor was basically saying how we
have to support is we have to support is
um and I was like shocked um you know
this was after 911 so I had become sort
of politicized after 911 um and I read a
lot of history read a lot of you know
following current events and stuff like
that and I definitely had a lot of
sympathy for Muslim people politically I
felt they they were getting oppressed
and the wrong end of the deal um and
this pastor was like I went up to the
pastor after the sermon I said I just
don't understand why we support over and
she said well that's because they
believe in the same God that we do
Muslims don't and I was like that's so
dumb like you're wrong like I I was like
a teenager like I know better than that
this person has a masters in Divinity
and they don't even know that right so
that left left a bad taste in my mouth I
had a lot of other things that I saw
hypocrisy and and then you start
questioning and things don't make sense
Trinity doesn't make sense the Bible's
been changed it's not doesn't read like
you know actual divine revelation so as
a teenager I left uh Christianity
specifically and and religion in general
I became an atheist um act three was
when I get to College okay so I went to
college of vas College in pipy New York
uh very good school and I started sort
of having different experiences that
kind of were destabilizing like what I
what I thought I knew okay um and part
of that was actually my a lot of my
studies was in political science so I
started out a history major then I
switched to political science political
Theory and what I focused on was
European colonialization right uh and
most of that was in the Muslim world or
at least a great portion of that was in
the Muslim world so I studied how it
happened why how they Justified it all
the dirty rotten tricks that they pulled
and played and everything that they did
so um but even more than that I started
to learn about sort of Muslims
resistance to it right and and sort of
uh the ideological component of it right
and I was really really impressed by
just how people now like non-muslims now
are really inspired by the faith of
Palestinians like how are these and like
people have converted like actually
accepted Islam by like seeing like these
per people are just being pulled out of
the rubble and they're still like
praying they're still thanking God and
you know like amazing like that was me
like at one point I was like these
people are like they're they've got all
the big forces and of the world against
them and they're still holding it down
it's like what is this thing right and
so I started poking around I had a
professor that was a Muslim I started
like doing research and stuff like that
I went abroad to study in Turkey I was
in estano for six months had an amazing
experience people they were so friendly
um and then I I just started when I came
back I actually took a class in Islamic
Studies um at the University it was
horrible it was taught by a professor
that was very like anti-islamic um and I
was like like basically arguing with her
in class and like you know defending
Muslims so it was crazy um but so then
after that I just started experimenting
with with prayer and fasting and stuff
like that I was like let me just try
this out and um it satisfied that thing
that I felt even as a kid where I was
like you should have to work for your
relationship with God right and so it's
like five times a day praying makes
sense you should have to pray five times
a day once a week what is this it's a
joke right fasting 30 days a year that
makes sense and once I started praying
in fasting like I loved it it was like
the coolest thing so um it was just one
thing after another uh little bit of a
funny thing was I actually fasted an
entire Ramadan before I even understood
what the shahada was and I had to take
the shahada so then like long story
short someone eventually told me like yo
you you should probably take the Shad at
this point so I did and then it was all
just forward from there wow Subhan Allah
that's that's one beautifully summarized
H all the important points and two
that's that's Allah do you have a video
I'm sure you have a video where you
spoke about this in depth yeah actually
towards eternity when I went to aul
recently within the last year um I
hooked up with towards eternity and
those guys uh in estanbul and I think I
went the most in depth in my in my
Converse story or my reverse story there
so if anybody wants to see all the
nitty-gritty details then you can go to
towards eternity and see that inshallah
amazing so you you mentioned which I I'm
surprised to hear subh Allah that back
in the day that is how you felt about it
so in light of recent events what has
happened recently what like how did you
feel when you heard these events on you
know take place well you know it's been
this has been the status quo right like
so so people and you look at the the
sort of propaganda machine that really
really trying to focus on October 7th
what happened October 7th and one of our
biggest interventions is that this is
not this is not start on October 7th
this has been 75 years right this has
been you know from the Inception of the
Israeli state which was unilaterally
imposed upon the Palestinian people with
you know closed door meetings between
the groups and America and the United
States you talk about you know Sykes
Pico and the balfor Declaration and all
the history this has been a rotten deal
from day one right it's fundamentally
flawed it was a mistake should should
have never happened yeah okay and that's
got nothing to say about living in that
land that's a whole separate issue
people try to conflate the two the state
of should have never happened yeah
period now where to go from here okay
that's a different question you know not
a question for this time necessarily but
we are living out the consequences of
that rotten deal that should have never
happened imposition unilaterally on a
people uh without their consent without
their you know even say at the table so
everything that's happened since then
the encroachments the land seizures the
settlers the dispossession of
Palestinian land the against them you
know the our parde state which is you
know on the books it's literally how
they run their country it's it's in the
laws right all of it is a consequence of
that original sin has an original sin
right and so when somebody reacts okay
we might not agree with how they reacted
but that's neither here nor there you
can't just focus in on how they reacted
and say oh my God how this is terrible
it's like no well you know okay maybe
but the way that he that the person
reacted is because this thing has been
going on and on and on and I would
challenge anybody any human being on the
face of this Earth to look me in the eye
and say if you were in right and you
lived like like you didn't like you you
lose family members every year right
from you got no food you got no medicine
you got no electricity you got very very
spotty you know like cell phone service
or no celf cell phone service at all
like this was your daily living uh you
know situation yeah what would that push
you to do that's a great question so
people need to just be real yeah and on
top of that there was actually Norman
finlin he he mentions that I think it
was the when who reported that there was
actually Point time when was calculating
the bare minimum calories they needed
just so they don't starve today so it's
it's even beyond the unlivable living
conditions or t them they can't leave
yeah blockaded in there with the So-Cal
so um something I find interesting is it
almost seems to be the case and this
something I want to ask you about that
whenever you have some crazy Muslim
terorist organization if you go back
throughout recent history you see some
kind of Western colonial state
intervention sure is that the case no
definitely I mean this is the thing
people they they try to escape this fact
by basically their islamophobic
arguments and I use that term
begrudgingly because I think there's
problems with it but let's just call
that for the sake of ease for people
watching the islamophobic sort of
assumptions that Islam that Islam is an
inherently violent religion that
religion in general is inherently
violent more than a secular state is
which is a big lie right all these sorts
of things like it's very easy to
shoehorn like these groups into that
like oh here they go again they've
always been fighting oh this is them
again Islamic Islamic extremism etc etc
which is all just you know like it's
just a bunch of I can't say it BS you
know what I mean it's like it comes back
to um you know who wants to wipe who off
the face of the matap yeah okay the
state of is wants to wipe Palestinians
off the face funny because people say
the opposite they say all their points
all of their talking points it's an
inversion you know what I mean it's like
they say that you know like the the
opposite side uses human Shields save it
human Shields interational actually
during um one of the operations a gate
something I forget what it was a gate
letter or something like that they
actually found didn't use any human
Shields but they reported did to the
extent where they would put them in a
window with a a rifle over their
shoulder from behind them and even know
this citizens that's why actually many
of them are coming out against and
against the government and demanding
they step down because they feel like
they're being used and they are you know
like the settlers are being used I saw
you know like 300 settlers being you
know given assault rifles yesterday
right it's like it's insane right so
it's like who's using human Shields
who's barbaric who's targeting children
and women who's like you know it's like
you know it's like sometimes you know
the person who's guilty projects
on the other right and it's like you
know you're assuming something of
somebody else because you're actually
guilty of it yourself and uh you know
even if okay like even if some of the
claims were true which if they are if
they are we reject them we don't believe
everything that comes out of their
mouths because they're Liars but if it
were true of course that's not a time we
reject that but given the position that
each of them are in you've got one side
with comp like the most desperate
situation that you could think of and
then the other side with the most
comfortable situation that you could
think of with the backing and complete
political and Military cover of the
United States of America which is a
mistake for US foreign policy which one
is less Justified the one with
everything going for yeah right it's
like if you do something wrong out of
desperation I at least can sympathize
with your despair I can at least
sympathize with your desperation even if
I disagree but if you've got it easy if
you've got $13.1 million a day of us tax
money which the US the the US gives four
times more than it does for the snap
program right um if you've got complete
political cover any sort of UN
resolution for the Security Council is
going to be vetoed by the United States
against you know you've got complete
media coverage CNN literally has isi
military personnel as spokespeople on
their Channel and they're just taking
the IDF sort of a version of things and
putting it up like it's fact you've got
all that and you're still using human
Shields and you're still babies and
women yeah that's cowardice that's evil
yeah let's just put let's just say it
how it is absolutely and there needs to
be consequences for whether it's from
the UN and the quote unquote
International Community whether it's
from here from there you can't let that
happen the world is is blamed the world
is blame worthy at this point do you
think this time the extent that they've
taken it is actually just backfiring and
it's reviewing yeah I do I think that
they overplayed their hand I don't think
that they expected this type of backlash
I was actually reflecting with a brother
the other day because you know we were
talking about the big issue for Muslims
before the escalation time was the lgbtq
issue and we saw how a similar thing
happened when it came to the
institutional capture that Lobby you
know actually uh was able to achieve
with you know the American Psychiatric
association and like the different sort
of you know schools and and and politics
and stuff like that but they overplayed
their hand right they're now like like
for elementary school kids and people
were like this is ridiculous we've had
enough and so then we they started to
experience blowback the same exact thing
is happening now with with Israel
overplayed their hand like they thought
that they could do whatever they wanted
and they actually you know like some of
these again these military personnel get
on a camera and say their intentions
their attentions like it's it's there
we're like they're saying that they're
going to go after civilians they say
that they're going to whatever so it's
like they they've definitely overplayed
their hand and this is the opportunity
that we have to finally Expose and
reveal and we've had the most means you
know us and Muhammad hijab have been
talking all this week about we're in the
best position we've ever been in the the
you know the state has never been weaker
you know I I don't think and our case
has never been stronger right and so
this is really a huge opportunity that
we've got to hit full force we've got to
let everybody know reveal the truth
share you know repost like whatever we
can do so that the the most amount of
people can possibly see what's actually
going on can change and hopefully we can
um achieve as much change as we can
inshallah and I think it's also
important to highlight why it's
different now back in the day social
media was not as you know proficient and
and out there as it is nowadays and and
people trusted other individuals a lot
less now that there's been a shift with
even people like Donald Trump saying you
know Fox News CNN fake news fake you
know big politicians who a lot of people
look up to are saying this is fake news
a lot of people are looking literally to
Tik Tok creators for news taking them as
objective sources like they used to take
the news channels and and on top of that
seeing what's happening on the floor and
seeing the members saying what they're
saying websites like breaking the
silence that have members talking about
the crimes they committed and talking
about why they're breaking their silence
these things are huge having Muhammad
aab on Piers Morgan recently that was
huge so it's it's because of our voices
like you mentioned because the content
that people make and if we keep going
inshallah we could really see in 2050
years a huge shift for the Muslims yeah
100% agree there was this video that
went viral you know how we hear these
things about babies being you know
deleted and grandmas and it almost
sounds fictional bro it's like that that
it's like everyone agrees that's that's
wrong there's no proof and then this
video of this this grandma that was
released yeah it went viral what were
your thoughts on that oh was hilarious
man because it breaks all the narratives
you know the the the was like really
scrambling to try to spin it some way
and you I actually saw some of the the
headlines and how they tried to spin it
yeah but she actually she's about to be
released and then she tries to shake the
guy's hand and he's kind of like
surprised you know and she thanks him
she said that she was treated well and
all this stuff which is honestly just
beautiful you know it's like as as
people have said before governments
trying to tell us what's true
Palestinians are showing us what's true
you know it's like it's your narratives
times out times run out people are going
to figure it out you know people aren't
aren't so stupid that they're going to
be fooled forever right it's like these
big bad barbarians you know supposedly
who some countries do not designate as
organizations right we have to be real
with that too because some these are
it's like okay what's the definition of
ter you know I I be frank with you
government's Terror organization like
just because the United States doesn't
list it as one United States could be
wrong yeah yeah and it's been wrong
about other things before so it wouldn't
be a surprise right um so yeah I mean
these things are are amazing and it's
also good to see because even as Muslims
like we fear that some of the things
that they're saying might be true you
know what I mean it's like because we
know what Islam says we know Islam says
you have to treat prisoners right you
can't kill civilians you can't kill like
non-combatants you have to like whatever
we have rules and so as someone comes to
us and they're like oh this is what you
guys are doing this is what you guys are
doing right we're getting pushed to
condemn something and these people are
liars in the first place so we don't
know whether to trust them or not but we
also in the back of our mind are like
man I really hope they're not doing it I
really hope they're not doing that you
know what I mean because that like it or
not they've been using them as an excuse
as a pretext to all cousins and anyway
you know so it actually gives us relief
to know that alhamdulillah they're not
doing that alhamdulillah they're
actually like following Islam you know
at least in some and they might have a
things that they're doing that we can
criticize or whatever but the the bigger
point is that this is fog of War you
know what I mean it's like and there is
definitely you can't trust everything
that you hear in the in the media and
everything that people say it's a very
important time to be critical well not
your PR and that wasn't the only report
by the way of someone one of the you
know people the captives saying oh they
were nice to me they they were
hospitable they asked me to eat a banana
off my counter like all these crazy
things there have been at least three to
four personally that I know of which for
the media game is huge because this is
the stuff they want to keep down and
here's the thing like if they had if
they actually had like people that were
standing up that were doing the things
that they said that they were doing it
would be non-stop coverage if if people
like from movements within or whatever
we saying the things that the Personnel
are saying on camera that would be
plastered 24/7 you wouldn't see anything
else except that so what does it say
that they're having to grasp at straws
and be like oh they their own people and
they bom their own
Hospital okay no they didn't you know
they're really trying so hard to form
this narrative that these people are
just bloodthirsty and they hate and
they're the reason why we have to go and
they're the reason why it's like and the
narrative's Fallen apart absolutely 100%
especially because like their arguments
nowadays when we have people online
speak speaking about the arguments their
arguments can be flipped back on them
like what they're doing is in
retaliation to what did well what was in
retaliation to what they've been doing
for the last take any sentence that they
try to pull with that and just switch
out the the names and they wouldn't
accept it which shows you that you're
just a racist at the end of the day yeah
you know one one one Ayah of the Quran
that I love is um where Allah says that
the truth the truth has come falsehood
had vanished CU
fals exactly and what that tells me in
the few minutes that we have is is that
when the truth comes it's not possible
to really believe a lie all that left is
just to reject the truth so now when
people see and hear what the is doing
what they're saying they see and hear
what the doing saying they see and hear
the captives who are what they proport
about these these so-called you can't
actually believe this previously
believed narrative anymore it's either
you accept the truth or you reject it
and just keep sticking like Ben chapiro
he knows the truth for sure but he's
going to keep sticking with these
talking points unfortunately defitely
and look at who these captives blame
when they go back to their homes they
blame they blame is yeah I remember I
don't know how how authoritative this is
but I saw four out of five actually
blame and his government and they they
were on the like break of a civil the
last few
months I don't want to keep going
because we have left any final final
question or final man there was this
ridiculous video that I saw of this this
CNN journalist she was prone right and
she was like oh my God there's you know
we're currently like oh yeah there's
people walking in the back strolling or
on bicycles they have to try man they
have to try so hard they have to try so
hard to keep the lie up you know and but
it's but they're being exposed and
they're taking the L man they're just
like going to look like fools you know I
mean all they have to do is play on
people's prejudices and that's all
they've been doing but the truth will
shine will shine through and so every
single one of us has a duty this is
actually the H I gave last Friday you
know um it's about you know being and I
used that a that you brought up that
every single one of us has the duty to
show the truth and people don't get it
twisted you know un fortunately they're
going to make us make it seem like
question our loyalty and and make us
seem like a fifth column and like
whatever that we're sympathizing with
this or that no no no if we didn't care
about y'all we would let you be with
your lies we want you to see the truth
we consider it a duty to you to show you
the truth and to bring you out of this
stupidity that youve delusion let's call
it delusion the delusion that you've
that's been covering your eyes for so
long we care about you enough to try to
bring you out of that so given the
blockades right now in under 60 seconds
what do you think you would recommend
Muslims to do right now that we can all
do at home uh the most immediate thing
is to push for a ceasefire immediate
ceasefire no conditions no whatever so
that has to do with keep up the social
media War the information War everything
that you're sharing you know break those
narratives there's been a lot of really
good work in trying to reshape the
language through which we actually talk
about these things because that's part
of how they win it too you go on the CN
CNN what do they call
it that's not true right like this is a
war from versus the Palestinian people
right and so little things like that not
letting people set the like like
Muhammad hijab did on Piers Morgan not
letting them set the tone I've said on
Twitter I don't think that um I don't
think that anybody should issue
condemnations anymore not until they
start condemning things like I refuse to
condemn anything that I clearly don't
have anything to do with until you
condemn stuff do you condemn you know a
partti do you condemn a racist state do
you condemn uh bom children and do you
condemn white phospherous and I was on a
a talk show locally the dude couldn't
even deny or or denounce chemical and
you want to make me look like I'm some
Savage you're the Savage you know what I
mean so we gota like Muhammad ja is 100%
right we ask the questions now it's like
that Meme right it's like we we ask the
questions now you guys don't don't have
the question we're going to ask the
questions now absolutely I think that's
a beautiful and Powerful note to end on
thank you so much for joining us may
Allah bless you we thank Allah for
facilitating this for us and thank you
so much for joining us thank you guys
for tuning and share it with your loved
ones your family your friends and people
who need
it we'll see you on the next
one thank you so much